we've been enough in measurement for a
little while now imagine all kinds of
things we'll be measuring perimeters
areas all kinds of different shapes that
we've been measuring right what's the
most recent one most recent country
round thing circles very good and we
learnt that the perimeter around a
circle in a special name what was it
called a circumference very good and its
area and its circumference has to do
with a special special number does it or
in both special pies is weird number
right 3.1415 bla bla bla bla bla so
strange strangely so we're we're going
to move from there is now that I think
about border missions now more
dimensions like before we get to that we
met a figure I want dimensions us what
is a division a dimension is a direction
that you can do one or two things in its
objection you can move in or direction
you can measure it right a direction you
can move or measure in so for instance I
could say you know I I can move left and
right along here right oh this is your
left right and this is your right okay
something back and forth it back before
so in some ways I've got one dimension
to make an interval on here okay one
mixtures from that side to this side and
we've seen one dimensional things before
for instance the number line right it's
got zero in the middle okay and you
remember we were covering integers okay
going to the right you've got like 1 2 3
4 5 etc and they're going to the left
you've got all the negative numbers okay
and left it right positive negative
that's the only direction she's going
yeah okay yeah so in this case what I
mean by a direction is like it's it's
the line I could move like you can go
back and forth but you're still going in
the same along the same dimension
same direction okay so in that case back
and forth about different ways of moving
along the same way okay right so that's
our dimension is okay so therefore we
move to these things they're all about
measuring in different kinds of
dimensions right if a dimensions
injection you can move a measure it okay
then a length a length is how much space
how much space an object takes off
I'm just gonna write it like that and
don't make any comment okay I like this
how much space an object takes off in
one particular dimension okay super
instance for instance well we have a
look at some of the shapes that we are
measured in the last few lessons okay
for instance I can say all right is a
rectangle he's a reckoning okay
what did I say all right what did slink
what's its name it's like this how much
space does this thing take up along this
direction okay that's what I made by
it's like oh I could have made this too
late that doesn't matter I could just
turn around the right thing okay since
how much space it takes up don't we go
along one particular line okay now the
reason why this is a great definition
even though it seems a bit like overly
technical is because from this
definition we can make perfect sense of
area and volume right if this is what
length business that area is the same
thing the same thing how much space an
object takes up but it's how much it
takes up in two dimensions instead of
one right it's the same thing in two
dimensions okay so for instance what are
we talking about
Judis right if I said okay this this
length across here rather than
estimating I'm just gonna actually made
so the length of this rectangle he is
approximately 25 centimeters okay
26 right so I might say that is my unit
of length okay but now if I go to area
and I'm going in two dimensions I've got
length and I've got width I need a
different kind of unit if if life is a
measure it in one dimension right
therefore when we go into area I'm gonna
have centimeters going this way and then
I'm going to have centimeters going this
way as well right so for instance if I
said before okay 26 centimeters and
let's just say for instance that this is
10 we know to multiply those we know
that area is just you know length times
width or whatever it is we multiply the
numbers 2016 10 26 times 10 which of
course is just 60 right but we should
also multiply the units we're gonna get
centimeters PG 260 centimeters squared
right like I could write centimeters
times centimeters but we have like index
notation which makes this a bit quicker
and succinct yeah so now it's just the
natural progression into this world that
we inhabit right that a volume is again
the same thing how much space and object
takes off it's the same thing yeah in
three dimensions rather than in two or
in one right so you know how I said oh
this dimension here I've got like back
and forth over here left and right when
we add in area it's not just left and
right it's up and down okay when we do
volume it needs to be another direction
to go in right so it's like if this if
this rectangle could come off the board
like into our 3d space like that yes
okay I could go up and down right so and
of course I'm come closer and further
right now therefore if you've got like
two 26 centimeters for 27 teams and 260
centimeters squared because I'm in two
dimensions when you have volume you
would expect for instance suppose this
now came out another I don't know let's
just say I didn't get very far
just two centimeters out from the board
okay I multiplied by the number two
which would give me what's double 260
520 very good but I also multiply the
units - right I've multiplied by
centimeters one more time which would
make it sense of meet is huge
very good so just like we say
centimeters we call these square
centimeters we'll call these cubic
centimeters right cubic cinnamon and in
fact on your book right now I'd like you
to get your ruler out get your lap I'm
gonna do mine stupid it's quit return
for a small I'd like you to draw a cubic
centimeter for me draw a cubic
centimeter so it should be 1 centimeter
by 1 centimeter that's the square of the
front right and then to make a cube out
of it you'd have to go one centimeter
into the page right which of course we
can't actually do but we could represent
it using lines that you try and mimic
what's going on so this is what we try
just to zoom in